il mérite pas notre confiance là on fait
pas un vote pour dire un blanc ça
surtout ce qu'il a dit on considère que
la feuille de route qui mis en place
n'est pas ne pouvait pas être une
feuille de route de rupture et elle ne
provoque aucun malaise supplémentaire à
celui qui nous avons déjà et il est
plutôt dans une tonalité assez offensive
au regard des menaces qui pèsent sur
notre modèle social
c'est donc absolument pas une confiance
en disant youpi ville bernard cazeneuve
c'est une confiance raisonnable car le
pays a besoin d'être dirigé et
manifestement en cohérence entre autres
président de la république et premiers